you have me over of course
how you feeling I haven't ever been
drugged her you were never in drag her
alright
wasn't are you ready to tell history
yeah let you do it yeah alright
this story will be about well him very
freezing down here I'm gonna tell you a
story about General von stupid it's the
American Revolution Washington troops
are freezing to death
they said Washington you don't know what
you're doing everybody around us is
dying they don't have anything to eat
they are freezing cold what are you
gonna do Washington says I'm gonna talk
to my buddy Ben Franklin cuz I don't
even know that Franklin was just
partying in Ferris it's very Franklin
learns of this Prussian war General von
Steuben he was trained by the King of
Prussia Ben Franklin says hey von
Steuben why don't you come to California
no Ben Franklin says why don't you come
to America and fight for us and von
Steuben's like look I already got kicked
out of pressure for being gay I'm okay
here in Paris it's okay to be gay in
Paris in Paris is like not okay to be
gay in Paris we're about to kick you out
if I Steuben says check please so far
seven shows that with cooks and butlers
he's dressed to the nines he's brain
FERS he's got a dog and he says hey I'm
von Steuben he looks at all of General
Washington soldiers
and he says look at this group of dogs
they're dying they're starving they have
no ammunition no love the soldiers are
like I don't like this guy
George why he says no no give me a
chance give me a chance give me a chance
and finds truman's like I am gonna whip
you guys into shape new coaches in town
vice-chairman starts training the
soldiers running through the ranks he's
stretching into the stretchers he's
yelling and impression then they go
what's he saying
Washington is like boy the guy doesn't
even speak English so he says bah blah
blah blah blah blah blah and they hear
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah what
are we gonna do but guess what young
captain shows up Ben Walker he says I
can understand all the blood loss I
speak Russian and I can help the
Americans understand him my student
turns over his shoulder and sees the
most handsome American he's seen so far
still there's into bonds this guy is
platinum blonde beautiful cheekbones
puffy lips Benjamin Walker says I will
be your guide and they become biased but
they have this this this training
montage so Benjamin Walker ends up being
exactly what they needed he helps him
with the troops by extremist starts
teaching them things he's like these are
knives you can use and stab people and
they're like that's great idea teach
them how to clean their teeth teach them
how to clean their bodies so they don't
get disease people are like we're just
trying to win a war man he's like this
is how you win a war
they start training harder and that he
says Ben Walker yelled them in English
and that guy says more squats more
squats come on
you literally turn you turned he trained
the army into butter
Gino ain't drinking games oh yeah I was
just thinking is there any way we could
take this shot oh what's that
yeah drink so it's a balance bring time
no it's battle Hill no it's the Battle
of Baron Hill these terrified kids are
just crushing it as troops start beating
battle after battle using the caches of
von Steuben to use the bayonets
they got all clean teeth and they won
their war Washington said von Steuben
you live with Constantine I say Ben
Walker Washington said I'm gonna give
you a house to live in and I want you to
live with that guy Ben walk Ben walk
that guy I will grant you the most
beautiful love ever so the army used von
Steuben's tactics for 100 years they
called the blue blue blue but that
that's why we're here safe so far Subin
saved the world
this story's like that movie Renaissance
man when Danny DeVito came was the
poetry teacher - no no it's not like
that
it's more like the guys from the world
cap okay Mighty Ducks
yeah that's it it's more like we were
mighty caps it mighty can write gasps
yeah
[Music]